I got several emails to set up today's
video so the first part is there is a
massive archive hidden in a working salt
mine in the north of England and the
second part is it's not just for
documents because there's so much space
available it's also an archive for
actual physical objects for Stuff
now it's very rare that someone who is
not an employee or an archive client is
allowed down here particularly to make a
video because there are public records
important government archives and a lot
of things that I'm not allowed to go
near let alone film confidentiality is
important and someone is looking over my
camera up shoulder to check where that
lens is pointing we are 150 meters
underground and about a kilometer into
that mine is deep store ready when you
are
the area that the mine occupies is
around about three and a half kilometers
east to west and about two and a half
kilometers north to south and at the
moment we're around about a kilometer
and a half away from the mining
activities what we use is what's called
a room and pillar mining Technique we
don't just extract great big massive
voids of salt there are massive pillars
of salt of which I'm actually stood next
to one now which make the mine so stable
and support the roof so where deep stock
comes in is we actually build in between
these pillars and in between these
pillars is what we call the repositories
or the rooms and then we play in the
floors they're painted we install the
racking we install the air conditioning
originally the mining started around
about 1850 and it really got going in
around about the Turner Century 1900
since then it's simply grown and grown
and grown up to the present day where
now we're extracting around a million
tons each year deepstal was set up in
the 1990s because we've got the perfect
atmosphere down here to store items the
salt crates that are naturally occur in
dry atmosphere and of course with the
racking nothing actually comes into
contact with the salt because this is
relatively a shallow mine we're around
about 150 meters you know four or 500
feet and because of the salt bed it has
created this natural ambient temperature
of 14 to 15 degrees along with a
relative humidity of 53 to 55 which
anybody in the archive and storage world
knows you know naturally occurring that
is absolutely fantastic what we've been
able to do is actually enhance these
conditions and modify them even more to
client requirements so by the use of air
conditioning and air filtration we can
make the atmosphere in here to really
whatever a client requires the
atmosphere in these storage rooms is
actually clearer than it is on the
surface it's almost impossible to get
across the sheer scale of the mine and
the archive on camera and out there
where it's still a working mine I can
taste salt in the air there's there's
clouds of it that that lands on you but
in here things are a little bit more
controlled it is public knowledge that's
somewhere in the many many vaults here
there are files from the British
national archives and core samples
drilled out for soil tests during the
construction of crossrail other than
that well deepstore aren't saying more
through wanting to be cautious about
revealing details of their clients
rather than any strict secrecy but the
folks who actually got in touch and
invited me here have a very different
reason for storing actual physical
things long term Laura Ashley is a UK
Interiors lifestyle and fashion brand
within the cabinets in this room there
are hand-drawn artworks some of them
hundreds of years old that have been
developed into wallpapers or Fabrics but
we also have Fabrics dresses rolls of
wallpaper meters of the fabric that
we've produced over the years stored in
the archive it's a continually growing
archive for Laura Ashley it's really
important for us to Archive the original
physical pieces so we can really
understand it's those techniques of how
they were made if you scan that if you
created a digital archive you would lose
that history to that piece when you can
touch and feel and see some of these
amazing antique documents you can really
see the brush Strokes in the artwork or
how they were printed initially and it
might be that we actually want to
recreate how they were printed not just
how they look we can't keep everything
it would be nice if entropy didn't exist
but until Humanity fixes that
preservation And archiving will take
skill time and money and the more you
preserve the more upkeep it takes
perhaps the most important decision any
archivist has to make is what to keep
and what to throw away so we've got
almost a hundred thousand items in this
law Ashley archive but that is by no
means ever think that was ever
manufactured we will always keep Masters
so wallpaper and fabric is core to what
law actually is original artworks would
never be thrown away the law Ashley
pieces in this archive date back to the
really early period so people may donate
pieces so that we're actually archive
that could be a law Ashley bowl that you
used to have in your house in the 1980s
or your mum's wedding dress from the
1970s it's fantastic for us to be able
to kind of see that with following in
the footsteps of the people who came
before us we've got over three and a
half million of items under storage be
it a box or be it an artifact we have
more than 40 rooms of the same standard
or even better standard than what I'm
actually standing in now this is
probably one of the largest single
repositories in the country currently we
occupy 14 to 15 of the actual mind void
area underground which means we've got
amazing amount of space to expand into
you know I mean really if you were to
convert this entire site eventually
you'd probably be able to store just
about every single archive box in Europe